hi everyone hey santa
i wish i could be there with you in real
life i know we do too and
hopefully soon very soon okay first up
we're going to the temple of beauty
hacks i mean what happened before tick
tock like
i finally know anything what
okay now the beauty bible alora reports
that the latest beauty trend goes
against
everything that we know about applying
makeup
the hack says to put your base products
on in reverse
so moisturizer first then light layer of
powder
setting spray primer and finally apply
foundation
michelle what is going on
this has actually been something that's
been done quite a bit especially for
people who do stage makeup
so we actually had an editor try it and
it's
great for some people not excellent if
you're anyone who has dry skin though
like me
so for someone who has oilier skin what
it does is that it creates this really
matte base so
everything that you put on over it just
has amazing staying power
so for someone with oily skin i would
definitely try it dry skin we found that
it kind of like cracked a little bit and
was not pretty
diana what do you think would you try it
uh this is
i'm so not a candidate for this one i
have the driest
lizard-like skin if i i would just crack
in seconds i'm like always fighting for
the glow and the idea of putting a
moisturizer on first and then a powder
on top
it's just counterintuitive because it
rubs all those great hydrating benefits
however exactly like you said this is
great for someone who has a much oilier
skin
yeah once maybe like the perfect selfie
the perfect canvas
but for me no that would be like kind of
conditioning my hair and then shampooing
after
oh my gosh that is a perfect way to put
it zanna
because i'm dry skin as well although i
still have the
chin of a 15 year old i don't know what
that's about
all right michelle your story yes so
hello giggles reports the latest trend
for thicker longer hair
is rice water and it's not new at all
it's actually an
age-old tradition practiced by the yao
women of china
they only cut their hair once at the age
of 18 and they have such long
beautiful lustrous hair they use rice
water to cleanse and condition
it's full of amino acids and vitamins b
c
and e you just rinse white rice retain
that starchy water that's left over
and then massage it into your hair and
your scalp i cannot wait to try this
my hair has changed uh so much
after two children and i'm really open
to
so many new things that i just didn't
need before so i cannot wait to try this
okay michelle i have to talk to you
about your instagram because it's filled
with the most
incredible nail art that we all died for
i even dm you i'm like oh my gosh what
is going on now
um so in honor of your amazing nail art
we've got one last tick tock
nail trick okay so you can apply a tiny
hair clip
to your finger so the polish doesn't
spill over when you're painting it have
you tried
i've not tried this but i am really game
for doing it right now by the way this
kind of hurts this actually but you know
kind of hurts it actually really helps
it does work a little painful but yep
not
painted the table like i usually do okay
michelle
um i am very excited because we've got
one more read from michelle's team at
allure and it's a list of innovative
asian owned beauty brands that you can
shop right now
and it includes products from um
charlotte chose
then i met you and david yee's
good light now this is so important not
just in this moment but as we stand by
the asian community with love and
support but also in
every moment as we continue to work to
embrace
everyone in the beauty industry and
michelle you have been such a leader
for all of us and i admire your
leadership
at allure you took a 30 year old
institution and totally expanded
what beauty looks like there and i was
wondering if you could talk about
what your approach was for that because
you changed the game um i think for me
when i started at alora five years ago
a big part of our mission was really to
redefine beauty and also redefine what's
beautiful
and at the time you know magazine covers
were not very diverse five years ago
so we started to do some really diverse
and meaningful covers
uh back in 2017 we had halima adden
who's an amazing model
in a hijab undercover with the lion this
is american beauty now
i remember we declared we were banning
the term anti-aging and had helen mirren
on our cover
last year we had billy porter who became
the first man ever
on the cover of the lore um when it
comes to asian representation
prior to 2018 there were
two asian women on the cover of the
lord's lucy liu your friend drew
and olivia munn and so post 2018 now
we've had eight asians on our cover and
so that is not by accident that is
because we really focus
on and prioritize diversity in our
coverage in a lot of different ways not
just asians it really was diversity in
in every sense
so you know as you were mentioning
before it's like the
in the asian american community right
now we are all really devastated
by what's happening and this rise in
violence and attacks
and i think a lot of us have been asking
like what what do we do
yeah so i think for us allure like our
part of that is to tell our stories and
to humanize us as people and as a
community because right now
we're feeling like we're invisible like
we're not seen and
and that we're honestly still seen as as
other and as foreign
so for us to be able to tell these
stories and humanize people and to
include
include stories honestly of working
class people too like salon workers
that's super important and it helps to
show that we're not all the same and
we're not other
and that has a really lasting effect
well michelle you're also part of the
non-profit gold
house and with the devastating rise in
violence we are all witnessing against
asians they've set up
a way that we can all help protect the
aapi
community can you share this please
yes definitely i'm so glad you mentioned
that gold house
is one of the organizers of the amazing
aapi community fund
gofundme and so gold house and cape
have vetted a whole bunch of these
grassroots organizations so they're
going to distribute
this fund out to some of these groups
you can find out more
at gofundme.com backslash aapi
it is a truly truly worthy cause yeah
and i reached out to you right away
michelle
and i knew that we wanted to do
something right away here on the show
and take action and i reached out to you
and you so generously pointed us in the
right direction and we posted everything
you suggested immediately and zanna
will you please tell us um about the
incredibly generous donation that milk
makeup
made well you know at milt makeup we
have always championed inclusivity and
diversity from the get-go
so obviously we wanted to basically
create awareness for all these amazing
organizations who are working so hard to
stop
asian hate so we donated 50 000
to the same organization it's so
important to us and not only that but to
help with the representation so on our
socials
in marketing in the outward facing
platforms we need to be representing too
and we like to think we all
always have but we will only continue to
support this
i for me i feel very
honored and lucky today because i get to
call you my friends
i i just i love you guys so much and i'm
really excited to be here with you today
and everyone at home um you can join us
please go to our website to find out how
you can support
stop asian hate we've been running it
for weeks we're going to continue to do
so
and thank you michelle thank you santa